this video is made possible by
brilliance you'll learn more about
brilliant later in today's video but if
you'd like to learn more about them
right now you can go to brilliant org
forward slash bio graphics you'll also
find a link in the description below my
Japanese pronunciation there is not
brilliant so bear with me in this video
I have a computer here I'm looking up
the stuff when I can sometimes I fail if
you won't ever go at me in the comments
go right ahead
during World War two in the second
sino-japanese war a doctor named Shiro
Ishii was responsible for creating
biological weapons of mass destruction
is she built a laboratory in Manchuria
called unit 731 on behalf of the
Japanese government its goal was to
create a weapon so deadly it could wipe
out the population of Japan's enemies he
used nearby Chinese villagers as his
human guinea pigs for these biological
weapons and experimented on men women
and even children when the war was over
the United States learned about Shiro
Ishii sadistic experiments while many of
the Nazis were sentenced to death for
their crimes against humanity in
Europe's concentration camps Shiro Ishii
was allowed to go free so what would
drive someone to become one of the most
evil men in history and why on earth was
he allowed to get away with mass murder
well that's what we're looking at in
this week's by graphics
[Music]
Shiro Ishii was born in 1892 in a
village called shiva yama are in the
chiba prefecture of japan
his parents were wealthy landowners that
came from a long line of daimyo or
feudal lords who owned the most land in
any given area the Japanese system of
prefixes or States had only just begun
in the 1870s so his parents were very
powerful and still had a lot of control
over the government in the Chiba
Prefecture throughout history these
wealthy landowners benefited from
indentured servants who farmed the
fields and they were able to enjoy a
lavish lifestyle even into the 19th
century these descendants of the daimyo
were still very much benefiting from
their family's fortunes at the same time
that Japanese people looked up to the
Emperor of Japan with a god-like
admiration even though they logically
knew the imperial family were mortals
they still had a very strong sense of
loyalty and they believed that the life
of someone living in the lower-class was
truly not as valuable as someone from
the upper class because of this Japanese
mindset shiroishi was raised to believe
that he truly was far more important
than most people not much else is known
about his younger years except to say
that it would seem like his path seems
very linear it is almost as if all of
his life experiences were preparing him
to experiment on human beings without
any sense of remorse Shiraishi
studied medicine at kyoto imperial
university but he wasn't interested in
becoming a doctor who healed the common
people in a hospital he became a surgeon
for the Imperial Japanese Army in 1921
and earned the rank of leftenant his
superiors were impressed with his
surgical skills so they sent him to the
Army Medical School in Tokyo for further
training they also paid for him to study
in a postgraduate medicine program at
kyoto imperial university even though he
did become a medical doctor like we said
he wasn't interested in healing patients
he was far more fascinated with studying
and experimentation he had a particular
love of biology and particularly
bacteria it used to grow deadly bacteria
in petri dishes and he called them his
pets in the early 1920s he finished his
many years of medical school and went on
a two-year trip around the world to
visit 30 countries
he was particularly fascinated with
staying in German
so that he could study the poison gases
that their army used during World War
one chlorine gas had been used as a
weapon of war but both sides began to
use gas masks as far as shiroishi was
concerned
gas was no longer an effective means of
killing another soldier in 1931 the
chinese territory of Manchuria was taken
over by Japan during the second
sino-japanese war this was a huge
victory for Japan and they were already
occupying Korea they were feeling very
confident that they could spread this
Empire to conquer the entire rest of
China sure if she saw this new
Manchurian territory as a perfect
opportunity for him to take his
theoretical ideas of biological weapons
and make them into a devastating reality
just like an evil villain in a Bond
movie he was searching for a plague that
was capable of wiping out the entire
human race or at least the enemies of
the Japanese Empire at this point surely
she had such a powerful position in the
military in government that he was able
to personally approach the Emperor and
request the funding to create a
laboratory in Manchuria after that
permission was granted he built a
massive compound called unit 731 it was
officially called the epidemic
prevention and water supply unit because
its true purpose of studying biological
weapons was supposed to remain a secret
they were given a huge budget which they
spent on state-of-the-art equipment unit
731 was similar to a Nazi concentration
camp in that it was an entire campus of
buildings which included holding cells
medical facilities and a gigantic
crematorium the Administration Building
where if she worked was so strong it was
the last building left standing after
being bombed years later but of course
you can't have human experimentation
without test subjects the Japanese
Kempeitai military police would grab
Chinese people off the streets of their
villages and arrest them they were put
on trains that arrived at unit 731 and
they were never allowed to see their
families again they have heard all ages
of men women and even young children
because they wanted to see how these
weapons affected all types of people
according to the military doctors who
worked there they were
forced to work at unit 731 without
really even knowing what they were
getting themselves into upon arrival
they would find doctors injecting
Chinese people with a deadly disease
like anthrax or the bubonic plague if
they spoke out against the experiments
it would be treason and they could be
executed for us for those who were
forced to work in unit 731 they had to
believe that this was all just a part of
war and killing these civilians was no
different than bombing an enemy country
in fact they believed that their actions
were far more noble than the average
soldier because they killed in the name
of science doctors would dissect human
beings while they were still alive
without using any anesthetic they wanted
to see what organs looked like while
they were still functioning and to learn
exactly how the disease would cause
these organs to fail some other subjects
were given a vaccine to the plague first
before exposing them to the disease this
way they were able to know exactly what
the strongest vaccines were for the
deadliest diseases in the world once
they perfected the formula they were
able to create enough antidotes for all
of Japan in this way unit 731 was making
breakthroughs in modern medicine but it
was at the expense of a great many
Chinese lives their holding cells they
were large enough that they could hold
up to 600 people at a time they called
these people Meritus which means logs
which only further to humanize them the
average lifespan for these prisoners was
only four to six weeks when their bodies
were done being used they were thrown in
a pile and burned in the crematorium
[Music]
in his laboratory Sharia she was
experimenting with the bubonic plague
which is known for being one of the most
deadly diseases in history but he didn't
want it to be the same plague that we
remember from the past
he genetically altered it to be
extremely potent and far more capable of
killing people than any previous strain
of the plague the bubonic plague can
only be transferred through blood so he
wanted to release disease-ridden fleas
on unsuspecting villagers in order to
test how strong it truly was they
collected rats which were perfect
incubators for thousands upon thousands
of fleas then the insects were carefully
gathered and put into containers their
first round of experiments had airplanes
dropping baskets full of fleas into
Chinese villages of civilians and it
works exactly as they had hoped between
1939 and 1942 plagues began to spread in
these villages one third of the total
population of each village was wiped out
these manufactured plagues were so
potent that once they were infected
people would just die within one to two
days
according to testimony by a man named
Jing foo his sister was infected with
this mega plague after being bitten by
one of the fleas the branzino neck was
so swollen it was as large as a head she
knew that if she stayed inside and
received medical treatment she would
infect the rest of her family with the
plague so she had to go into the middle
of a field and die alone there family
members could not get near her and they
had no choice but to burn her body in
the field where she lay while baskets
full of fleas may have worked with
low-flying planes surely she knew that
if he wanted to infect enemy countries
they would need to drop actual bombs
filled with fleas the only issue was
that the fleas would of course die in
the explosion
he figured out that by creating clay pot
containers he could drop a so-called
germ bomb that would smash when it hit
the grounds and the fleas would stay
alive but they didn't just stop at the
bubonic plague they experimented with
anthrax and typhoid as well after
dropping these bombs on even more
Chinese villagers the Japanese soldiers
showed up in all white lab suits
covering their entire body they would
commands villagers to come out of their
homes and they would find subjects who
had been infected by the plague and
performed dissections in the middle of a
field while their friends and family
watched on to shiroishi it was
all about gathering data and statistics
these people they were just numbers on a
page they were not actual human life
stem the Kempeitai were even given candy
from unit 731 and instructed to show up
to villagers and hand out the sweets to
small children
while Chinese villagers interpreted this
as an act of kindness the candy was
actually laced with anthrax the
scientists would later arrive and
observe parents beginning to panic as
their children died in their arms as
time went on the unit expanded their
human experiments beyond diseases they
also did experiments on frostbite and
the effects of shrapnel wounds this
involved strapping people down to a
wooden plank before blowing up a bomb
next to them all of this was just so
they could study how a human would be
blown apart by different types of
weapons so I think now is probably a
good time for a little breather this
one's a bit intense I mean science it's
responsible for the devastation of lives
as we're seeing in this video but it's
also responsible for the saving of
millions use the right way science
changes the world in remarkable ways for
the better and that's why I'm pleased in
this video to tell you about brilliance
and I know as always these ads in the
middle they're less than awesome but
brilliant are fantastic for sponsoring
this sort of longer content because it
allows us to share the darker lessons
from scientific history in a thoughtful
way brilliants are a science learning
platform that allow you to learn through
active learning which summed up is
basically the opposite of that feeling
of reading a complex paragraph about
some principle and then just having
absolutely no clue what on earth it was
going on about even on the 10th
read-through and they don't just cover
the basics although they do cover those
as well but it goes through two really
complex things like advanced statistics
I was recently going through a course on
statistics particularly the one lying
with statistics it's an amazing primer
on how to be aware of when the media is
misusing statistics to push your opinion
one way or the other
brilliance makes even complex
statistical concepts easy to understand
they give you something super short to
read it's it's very easy and then you
immediately apply it to a problem and
then you just rinse and repeat that and
all of a sudden you're understanding
things that you never thought you would
be I've been using brilliant for a while
you should just give it a go to see how
easy it is to start understanding
complex subjects so support by graphics
by going to brilliant dot-org /bi
graphics and now let's get back to
abusing science even though she Russia
and unit 731 had developed these deadly
weapons they never made this public
knowledge or threatened to use the germ
bombs some historians believe that if
the Americans knew about these bio
weapons ahead of time they would have
never dropped the atomic bombs on
Hiroshima and Nagasaki for fear of
mutual destruction but if you think the
Allied powers were safe from the
sadistic experiments going on in
Manchuria well think again
Cherie she plans a long-distance attack
on the United States called mission
cherry blossoms at night they attempted
to launch balloons that were filled with
deadly diseases like cholera smallpox
and the bubonic plague as well as
anthrax botulism an estimated 9,000
balloons were sent across the Pacific
Ocean but only 345 of them actually made
it to the United States many of them
were shot down and some landed in the
ocean or in forests or fields
considering there were a lot of UFO
sightings at the time it might be
possible that some people were seeing
these germ balloons and mistaking them
for something else there was actually
only one of these that caused any
casualties it landed in a town called
Bly Oregon on May the 5th 1945 a Sunday
school teacher named Elsie Mitchell was
on a day trip going on a picnic in the
mountains with a small group of her
teenage students her husband Archie who
was also their minister was driving the
car up the mountain Elsie was a few
months pregnant and she got sick during
the car ride husband pulled over to let
her out to get some air they had parked
near a crew of men who were doing
construction work on the road the
students in Elsie decided to take a
short walk through the woods and Archie
began to speak with the men he then
heard his wife's voice say look what I
found dear followed by an explosion
Elsie had come across one of the
balloons she had no idea that it was
actually a bomb and approaching it she
triggered the explosion Archie and the
crew ran towards the sounds and they
found the bodies of Elsie and her group
of students lying dead on the ground
while most Americans were kept safe from
Shirou Ishii's experiments those who
were stationed in Asia during
world war two well they weren't so lucky
in 1944 and 1945 American prisoners of
war were in a city called mud Caen they
were visited by Japanese doctors many of
them had already been in captivity for
several years at this point the Japanese
wanted to see if their results were any
different on different races they
injected the men with various deadly
diseases and repeated the exact
experiments that they're done on the
Chinese many of these men died and the
ones who survived were only kept around
so they could carry away the bodies of
their friends when World War II was over
the Allied forces won and as they took
away power from Emperor Hirohito in
Manchuria China had defeated the
Japanese as well there was nowhere left
for Shiro Ishii to hide Nazi war
criminals they were being brought to
trial in Nuremberg in 1945 and 1946 and
many of them were being sentenced to
death for their crimes against humanity
the Japanese military still awarded
Shiro Ishii with medals of Honor and a
healthy pension for his retirement in
their eyes he was a hero for the country
but he knew that America would not feel
the same especially once they heard the
stories from the POWs Shiro Ishii
commanded his doctors and soldiers to
never speak of the experiments that went
on in unit 731
but of course they learned about the
experiments through the American
soldiers who survived the American
government approached history but
instead of arresting him they asked to
make a deal they wanted his data in
exchange for immunity Shiro is she knew
that this was the only way he could save
himself he promised that if they
pardoned all of his crimes the US
government could benefit from having all
of the scientific information that they
had gathered from their experiments in
the United States there are ethical laws
in place so that American scientists are
never allowed to experiment on human
beings by law they can only experiments
on animals for this reason the
government knew that these experiments
were truly valuable because it was
information that they would never be
able to receive on their own it's one
thing to inject a rat or a rabbit with a
disease but it's a totally different
thing to actually know the results on
human beings and more importantly the
Americans would gain access to the
vaccines that sure
she develops for some of the deadliest
diseases known to mankind they agreed to
trade his data in exchange for his life
and they even paid him two hundred and
fifty thousand dollars and in modern
money that's about 2.6 million all of
the scientists and soldiers who were
involved with unit 731 were happy to
keep the secrets because they were
deeply ashamed of their participation
with a project some of them even felt
too ashamed to return to Japan because
they were afraid that people would learn
about their crimes a few of them even
tried to live in China under new
identities the New York Times tried to
expose this by publishing an article
about his human experiments in 1946 but
beyond that the events gained for a
little media attention since all of
these atrocities happened in Manchuria
they were technically a part of the
second sino-japanese war and not World
War two even though both wars were
happening simultaneously for Americans
it was overshadowed by the thousands of
testimonies coming out of Europe about
the Holocaust but of course the Chinese
people they've not forgotten even to
this day many Chinese people still hate
the Japanese for what happens during
this war however most Japanese civilians
were unaware of issues human experiments
and they consider themselves to be
mostly victims of the war after the
nuclear bombs were dropped on Hiroshima
and Nagasaki the Japanese surrendered
and there was never the chance for them
to start a massive global plague so what
about those POWs in the 1940s government
officials approached them and demanded
that they sign a nondisclosure contract
they promise never to expose the truth
about what had happened to them in
Manchuria however in the 1980s many of
those soldiers felt that they had
nothing left to lose and they came
forward to testify that they had been a
part of these human experiments it
wasn't until the 1990s that Japan
officially acknowledged that unit 731
was real and it wasn't just a conspiracy
theory Shirou is she went on to live
into old age and he died at the age of
67 even after the wars are over the
plagues that Shiro Ishii unleashed in
China continued to spread and kill
people for years to come his exact
number of victims is unknown some
estimate that he was responsible for
tens of thousands while others say the
number we
hundreds of thousands of people so I
really hope you found that video
interesting just to reminder that you
should check out brilliant you can find
a link to them in the description below
also don't forget to subscribe to this
channel if you liked it and also give us
a like why not and thank you for
watching
[Music]